all right let's grab uh some details on
berfulsa i have a standalone video
on my um channel
so if you just search for i think i
titled it what is berfold's law
uh to try to capture people doing the
intentional searches on the definition
of it
so you can find that um on my youtube
channel if you want to just you know
spend some time on the details of that
but let me just read you
what uh they have defined it as uh let's
throw it up on the screen here too
all right boom boom boom that's it okay
so you should be able to see that but
there's a psychology today article here
uh false law women rule why can't a
woman be
more like a man the false law maintains
that the female
not the male determines the conditions
of the animal family
where the female can derive no benefit
from association with the male
no such association takes place today we
would say relationship rather than
association
so this guy robert fault was an english
surgeon
and an author now this is something that
you can't dismiss
as fiction because it's more fact than
fiction based on evidence when
when you start paying attention to the
animal kingdom inclusive of human beings
um we already know of course that women
wield the ultimate veto power in the
mating game
uh if you guys aren't aware of this
women are the gatekeepers to
sex men are the gatekeeper men don't
know this for the most part most guys
are oblivious like oh they don't know
that they have this power but
men are the gatekeepers to relationships
um so you have to understand that you
have some power in this dynamic
respect it and use it and wield it
properly um
it is women who give the thumbs up or
thumbs down to any advances or proposals
from men
right we're talking about sexual
proposals here obviously uh berfolt
embellishes this truism by asserting
that intimate relationships between men
and women result from a calculated cost
benefit analysis from
by women now i think it should be noted
that
women aren't sitting there with their
calculator or their calculus you know
spreadsheets and
excel documents calculating the
cost-benefit analysis
of a man it's almost like their firmware
is designed by mechanism of survival
to be able to very quickly
estimate and establish these things okay
men on the other hand will sit there and
use spreadsheets you know there's
um there's lots of examples of famous
spreadsheet men that have posted things
on the internet throughout time like
you know they'll keep like a spreadsheet
of dates and when
and where their wife is either intimate
with them or declines their advances for
intimacy
uh guys are like the you know calculated
spreadsheet dudes
women use their innate firmware
to make this analysis as he's breaking
it down over here
will she or won't she acquire net gain
from any relationship with a man
so think about it this way men
are like men are givers
you know we're even built mechanically
when it comes to intimacy to be givers
the way that our junk is built and women
are the receivers throughout history
millions of years of evolution we would
go out and hunt
and women would you know typically stay
behind and gather up and take care of
the small children
um and then we'd bring stuff back and
you still see the same
the very same thing today if you take
the list you know take a look at the
list of the world's billionaires
um most of the women on the list of
billionaires had acquired their wealth
not by function of their own work ethic
or work itself but as an acquisition of
uh either divorce or inheritance okay so
divorce they would have inherited it
from
their husband he would have done the
work uh for example mackenzie bezos
there's a lot of people that argue that
well you know she was with jeff from the
from the get-go and amazon wouldn't
exist if it wasn't for mckenzie and blah
blah blah
no go read the biography on
bezos on and on amazon it's called the
everything store
she's hardly even mentioning the damn
thing right
but she acquired half of his wealth as a
function of divorce so
women innately will make these
calculations in their head
and analyze what use a guy has to them
um it's it's just a fact reality of life
you know
there was a very clever line that chris
rock once used in a stand-up i think it
was um
was it never scared her tambourine i
think it was tambourine
tambourine was a good one that one was
on netflix neverscare is actually even
better
but um he said in that only women
children and dogs are loved
unconditionally men are only loved under
the condition that they provide
something
right this is true any guy that has been
in any number of relationships that's
seeing them
come and go and fall apart well agree
with that it's very hard to argue that
um anyway let's carry on with his
summary here because it's not that long
revolt continues with three corollaries
to the law even though a woman has
accrued past benefits from her
relationship with a man this is no
guarantee of her continuing the
relationship with him
translation what have you done for me
lately um
i've told the story before so let's sum
it up again real quick i've i've
dated a lot of divorced women because
after i got divorced i figured you know
let's download the apps and all sort of
stuff and we'll start going out and
you know uh i did the typical blue pill
sort of thing and started dating women
my age who
happened i'll be enforced with children
in tow and you start to have some
conversations with you know with these
checks
and they start telling you these stories
about how they would bounce on their
husbands
they would leave their husbands men that
they you know vow to
love cherish and sickness and health and
death do his part and you know all those
lyrics
all of a sudden he's rendered useless
and she leaves and you ask some
questions like well
and you know do this for yourself
gentlemen like you know ask these
questions when you get out there
um you know you ask these women well why
did you leave him you know because he
was good enough when you married him he
was good enough to father the kids so
what all happened oh you know he was he
wasn't able to keep a job
uh you know if his boss was mean to him
he would quit i remember this one chick
was telling me that she got to the point
where
um she'd basically have sex with her
husband like once a month and then she
would go in the bathroom and cry
like because could you imagine
this chick was like an animal right but
in her marriage during that time she
didn't want anything to do with a guy
didn't want him to touch and he was a
handsome dude right didn't want him
didn't want
him to touch her but because he wasn't
able to hold down a job because he kept
either getting fired or laid off or
quitting
and she used to make fun of him like oh
my boss was bees mean to me
right and mock the guy she wanted
nothing to do with them as far as
intimacy and she
and she left the guy so again even
though a woman has accrued past benefits
from her relationship with a man there
is no guarantee of her continuing the
relationship with him
again translation what have you done for
me lately goes right back to the chris
rock thing you know
men are only loved under the condition
that they provide something women like
to acquire stuff from men
mackenzie bezos half of jeff's
right and by coincidence she didn't even
keep half of his she just threw it
away
and did all this virtue signaling to all
these associations and non-profits
so that's so that's the first of three
corollaries with berfold's law
by the way guys if you want these mugs
they're on the store tab of the um
youtube channel um
number two if a woman promises a man to
continue her relationship with him
in the future in exchange for a benefit
received from him today her promise
becomes null and void as soon as a
benefit is rendered
translation i will gladly pay you
tuesday for a hamburger today that's the
way he you know it's been defined in the
article but basically
what we're saying again is her promise
becomes nullified as soon as the benefit
is rendered so
in so like when you take wedding vows
for example right you know the wedding
veils are always like
in sickness and health and and richer
and poorer and blah blah blah
well they're not hearing the poor and in
the sickness part usually
they're okay with the richness and the
healthy part but if there's problems
with money or health
um you know the clock could start
ticking down to the end of the end of
the relationship
because as brefault indicated her
promise
becomes null and void as soon as the
benefit is rendered
it's right here her promise becomes null
and void as soon as the benefit is
rendered so consider that
women's loyalty is fleeting it's you
know
everybody's all like oh you know
monogamy and you should just be like
with one person you shouldn't cheat on
people and blah blah blah
i have a chapter in my book again
unplugged alpha go to amazon
it's one of the longer chapters and it
deals with
humans promiscuity it's i think the
segment of the chapter is called
promiscuous primates is what i titled it
um humans aren't monogamous
in fact monogamy in the animal kingdom
is quite rare right
um there's very very few animals like
true monogamy as it's defined in the
animal kingdom like there's um
i don't know what the bird is it's some
kind of big ass like albatross bird uh
somewhere in the arctic or the antarctic
but it mates for life
and they go out to sea and they go and
you know
get their fish and they bring it back to
the nest and if one of the birds dies
the male or female dies while it's out
let's see a shark jumps out of the water
and
grabs it and eats it that's it there's
no other
mate for that bird it just dies a
spinster
it it you know you could say it goes and
gets some cats or some pet dogs in a
box wine subscription but that's like
the female version of today but
in in in nature that's it there's no
other mate for that bird
okay that's what monogamy looks like
that's what true animal monogamy looks
like
humans are not monogamous we are
probably one of the most promiscuous
animals on the plot
on the planet to give you an idea um
even promiscuous
primates okay chimps bonobos that sort
of thing
they have sex something like i think it
was seven or eight hundred times for
every pregnancy
humans have sex about a thousand times
for each instance of
a pregnancy you can see very quickly
that there's a lot of
you know intimacy going on around the
world and not a lot of
pregnancies coming out of it humans use
it
um for like
it has very very little do with
reproduction for us yeah it's it's it's
the origin it's the actual
function of it but when you take a look
at how humans behave
how almost nobody is with the same
person they lost their virginity to
one of the thing you know things that i
love is when chicks are all like
well you know i'm just monogamous and
that's how it it's like okay well how
many partners have you had
ten okay well you're not monogamous then
are you right because if you were then
you would have still been with the
person you lost your virginity to well
yeah but
you know i just want to be with you and
i don't want to share you okay it's
because they want you know
exclusive rights to you and your
resources
you